bonjour à tous c'est donc maintenant
officiel le futur héros pour
international du grand ouest verra bien
le jour un autre dame des landes le
projet date de trente ans il devrait
être une réalité à l'horizon 2010 il
devrait se substituer à l'actuel
aéroport de nantes et devrait être
dimensionnée pour 4 à 5 millions de
passagers
retour sur une annonce politique avec le
trône elle sans concurrencer les
aéroports bretons existants notre dame
des landes basé entre rennes et nantes
est maintenant définitivement lancée cet
aéroport international renforcera les
aéroports bretons sur les liaisons
nationales et transversale le futur
aéroport intercontinental vise un
potentiel de 4 millions de passagers
dans l'ouest principaux aéroports
régionaux seront développés en respect
des contraintes environnementales
parce qu'il constitue un ver at
véritable atout d'aménagement du
territoire et développement économique
et donc les capacités par exemple du
futur aéroport de notre dame des landes
seront adaptés à sa vocation de
plateforme d'échangés entre l'ouest et
les autres pôles notamment européens
le futur aéroport de l'ouest doit
maintenant être étudié par les élus
régionaux de bretagne et des pays de la
loire
la consultation va être lancée jusqu'au
15 avril pour une décision définitive
courant et et 2001
ce n'est que vers 2010 que les usagers
pourront s'envoler de notre dame des
landes à destination de l'asie ou les
états unis
[Musique]